is it possible for you to steal man to
play devil's advocate against yourself
and say that
vladimir zelinski
is fighting for the sovereignty of his
nation
and in in a way against russia but also
against the united states it just
happens that for now the united states
is a useful ally
but ultimately the man the leader
is fighting for the sovereignty of his
nation who thinks he thinks so yes and
he could be he could say that but he's
not acknowledging that the sovereignty
of his nation was stolen but in 2014
when the with a coup d'etat that brought
uh
that brought this sec this right sector
into power
and they have controlled the country
since then it's it's is it's thuggery
what they've done
the medvedev case is a case in point
they just take what they need
they go to a house and they they have
how many people have been killed aren't
serious people uh journalists killed by
the
the these uh battalions that's what
people don't realize in other words you
can't speak out you can't a person like
me would have been on the death list on
day day five
uh you don't there's no opposition to
zolensky so he doesn't have a real
sovereignty
it was a stolen sovereignty do you think
uh president zelanski would accept an
interview with you
today actually from
since i made ukraine on fire
uh documentary which perhaps you've seen
which
records the
the incidents of 2014 and the and the
maidan
uh demonstrations and shows you the
dishonesty behind it
no i think that they've been very
negative and
they would kill me if i was in ukraine i
mean they don't have any uh
these people are very tough these are as
rough as they come in my opinion and
i've seen rough in my life i mean these
guys are not playing with fair at all
they they these are death squads
no i don't think and zelansky would have
nothing to do with it but of course
it would be dangerous for me and they've
been very hostile in their
in their policies to any any ukrainians
abroad are also threatened
in other words you could be in paris but
if you're if you speak out too much you
i think ukrainians know that they're
going to be targeted and i think that's
part of the reason they don't talk
a lot of them you know you have to take
the anti-russian line but i think a lot
of them are divided so you think
you would be killed and zelonski
wouldn't even know about it so there is
well i'd be i don't think i don't if i
was killed certainly abroad no they
wouldn't kill me abroad i think they'd
like figure out no no no no if you
travel to ukraine i mean i wouldn't get
it i wouldn't get in
except through donbass i'd come to there
are some americans in donbass who are
reporting on the war there and i read
their reports actually they're pretty
interesting because they show you the
cruelty of what's going on but never
mentioned in the west never that's
what's so strange about this
this this is a modern world that we're
living in yet this information is not
coming out to the mass of the people and
on the contrary the united states has
closed down
all the all the prop all the rt
all the uh all the information centers
that are possible alternative news
getting to the american people they've
seriously made an effort and the bbc the
english and france i was shocked when
france closed rt down because rt is
actually pretty good they yes they may
you could call there are distortions but
you know as well as i do because you
hear you speak
that rt has done a very
brave job of putting correspondence into
the field in very dangerous positions
and they've gotten great footage
of some of the violence that's going on
well given the wall of propaganda in the
west
i also see the wall of propaganda in
russia the wall of propaganda in china
the wall of propaganda in india
what do we do with these walls of
propaganda yeah let's talk about russia
because i you and you would know more
about it but my last experience there
newspapers it was more interesting
there's
put it this way when i went to venezuela
the united states was saying
back then that chavez controlled the
press i get to venezuela and there's
nothing but criticism of chavez in the
press it was owned by the the oligarchs
of venezuela and who hated him so it was
across the board that's why chavez
opened the uh
the state television
spent more money on it and advertised
his point of view through state
television but this in russia uh there
is uh what i saw was criticism i met
with a publisher who got the nobel prize
of that famous newspaper
and his point of view at that time when
i spoke to him a few years ago was
we're operating there is criticism of
him but you know we you can't call for
the overthrow of the government
nor in venezuela nor in the united
states for that matter if you call for
the overthrow of
the government of the united states
you're going to be in deep trouble well
all right so to push back on that it's
interesting it's so interesting because
we mentioned elon musk and there's a way
that people sound when they speak freely
when i speak to i have family in ukraine
i have family in russia when i speak to
people in russia let's put my family
aside when i speak to people in russia
i think
there's fear
i think
they don't
um sometimes when you call for the
overthrow of government that's important
not because you necessarily believe for
the overthrow of the government but you
just need to test
test the power centers
and make sure
they're uh responsive to the people and
i feel like there's a mix of fear and
apathy
uh
that
it has a different texture than it does
in the united states
that worries me because i
i
would like to see the flourishing of a
people in all places
as i said my impression was that there's
far more freedom in the press and was it
was pictured by the west and and that
means different points of view because
the russians are always arguing with
themselves i've never seen a country
that's so contentious there's more
there's more
intellectuals in moscow and
the cities and than you can believe and
and you know the russian people there
they've been fighting government for
years
back from the 1870s zara's times they're
always plotting against the government
and the intelligence is known through
history as being
contentious and anti-government in many
ways
and uh we see the same thing educated
people turning against russia i don't
appreciate those people because i think
they're very
spoiled and they don't understand some
of the stuff that's going on in the west
but we have a lot of russians in in the
europe and america
that attack uh russia and sometimes
don't understand that they are under
pressure from the united states and they
don't understand the size of the
pressure
and it that's why putin connects with
the people because he he represents the
common more the common man
who's who's saying to you your interests
are threatened russia is threatened we
are representing only the interests of
russia not we're not an empire we're not
going to expand
he has no empire intentions all the west
pains in his empire
i see no evidence of it
why didn't he do something in all these
years nothing he did nothing except
defend the country in georgia and in
chechnya so the imperialist imperative
is coming more from the west
it's the imperialist agenda
going back to uh i'm sorry where we left
our discussion off i mean i was going to
go on with america not only being
censored has closed down now
closed down and you say it's not it's
not fear well it is fear
i am scared because
if you get your facebook page suspended
or your youtube your twitter account
thrown off a lot of good people are
getting there
thrown off
you can't say you can't speak out it
affects your business it goes back to
the 1950s when my my father's world when
you could not express any sympathy for a
soviet union without endangering your
job without basically being not trusted
you had to be part of the program to get
along to go along
same thing when uk united kingdom i mean
for all their talk this boris johnson is
an idiot
but all their talk about do you remember
their policies with the ira in ireland
when ireland was threatening them they
cut off the ira completely jerry adams
who was a a wonderful guy i met him
was not allowed to even be heard in
britain during certain years in france
all constantly through the algerian war
the algerians were not allowed to be
heard the algerian war for independence
divided france greatly
you could not even show paths of glory
world war one film uh in france for i
don't know 20 years after it came out
censorship is a way of life when
democracies also feel threatened they
are much more fragile than they pretend
to be a healthy democracy would take all
the criticism in the world and shrug it
off and say okay that's what's good
about our country well i'd like to see
that in america it used there are times
it's been like that but it's it's so
scary now so it is scary that's that's
what i was trying to say it's not
unscary to me um in china i would say to
you yes it's much scarier to me because
there is
the internet wall that they cut off and
i got into problems in china too because
i said something in years ago about you
have to discover your own history you
have to be honest about mao you have to
be you have to go back and and let's
make a movie about mao that
upset them you know and show his
negatives
so china has been much more sensitive
than russia about criticism much more
and it is a source of problems but on
the other hand china has
a lot of grievances a lot going back to
the 19th century and the british
imperialism of that era and the american
imperialism
you